seth rogen you've worked with an actual
tiger I did yeah
like a real real tiger or like a real
tiger yeah it was very counterintuitive
I'll be honest yeah I mean I movie
called the interview that almost started
a war he might have heard of it all this
time for you it was a horrible
experience yes yes it's bad to be blamed
for almost starting a war it's not fun
yeah super weird uh you know because you
must be just getting on with your life
we've got a bay we made a city comedy
yeah that's a dick and then the
president was talking about it
you know what yeah it was really bizarre
I had personal security and then one day
they just went away look I guess I'm
safe huh yeah but there was you I grew
in your house and everything
well the studio provided the filmmakers
with security in case someone from North
Korea was gonna kill us I guess and then
literally one day they were just gone
Edmund will you get no I called everyone
else I was like is your guys still there
they're like no my guys gone I was like
maybe this is it this is the attack but
it wasn't the studio just didn't want to
pay for security
to say by the way ya know he was little
just what bored he got came out I was
like hey you know he's not there anymore
yeah and I thought maybe in North Korean
taking him out no instead Sony just
don't want to pay for him anymore uh but
yeah it was a weird weird weird
experience but part of the weirdness was
you look you actually wrote a scene yeah
you you wrote this yes with a real tiger
I wrote yes and we thought we'd be able
use visual effects like in Life of Pi
and have a computer-generated tiger and
then we realize that we had no money and
so we had to get a real tiger from
Toronto I asked the guys who tight yeah
no I actually asked the guy where the
tiger came from and he said he got it
from a stripper
Richard crane ciggie that's quite the
act
it was quite after my son targeted
exactly
and don't touch her and the tiger
trainer god bless him if you were to
make a list of things you did not want
to hear a tiger trainer say he
systematically ticked every single thing
on that list he would be like well I
would be like is it safe you'd be like
well they are killing machines hey
that's cool and he's like so we're like
is this gonna be okay to shoot he's like
yeah you don't plan on shooting this at
night do you like yeah it's a night he
said well they hunt at night and really
gives it more dangerous at night he's
like it's around 30 to 40 percent more
dangerous were like 30 to 40 percent
more than what like what's our baseline
Tiger level of danger he's like as long
as it's not in a big open space and
we're like it is in a real
just like should we not do this like
should we just not do it and there was
I'm not joking 15 seconds of silence and
he goes not we can do it I've been the
trainer's son who is 18 years old
was the guy who was training it and cuz
we were like lies you're 18 year old son
doing he's like he has a much better
relationship with the Tigers and there
was one boomer he got to fight with his
dad while they're holding a tiger a zoo
like shut up dad I'm doing this
originally there's a [ __ ] tight in
here no one got killed by the time
state secrets there you know love us you
told it drama school if you don't lay
off the church and never play Juliet
so which one point Juliet I'm in tasted
chips